I was looking at a bunch of headlines
that had come out recently to do with
reality TV dating
shows what do you think are the lessons
that young people are taking about love
given how many reality TV shows are to
do with coupling up and breaking up and
making up it's about winning yeah it's
all about competition essentially what
we've done is taken love and turned it
into a game show now there's no way that
won't have a chck or down effect on
society what we're learning is to cheat
on them before they can cheat on you get
to caser more and couple up before they
can do it themselves so essentially
we're going into relationships we're
treating our partners as opponents and
who can win and the prize of this kind
of competition is who can be the
lonliest fastest who can create the
loneliest lonely relationship faster who
can get single faster so if I cheat on
you first or if I don't text back first
or if I do I win but what are you
winning what's the trophy of these games
the trophy is a lifetime of loneliness
so essentially we've made the prize
depress depression is the prize of
depriving yourself of Love unfortunately
yeah I mean you've got experience in
that did you find that it became a
competition while you in there so I was
pretty bored for most of my for all of
my experience on love Island I was also
going through an existential crisis
because I was faced with a bunch of
people that I thought I was right I was
adamant that I was this big name on
campus party boy and then I go on love
Island and I'm faced with people who are
the role that I was pretending to be
yeah and i' just read Paulo quo's The
Alchemist as well it was like the first
book I'd read in probably a decade um so
I was kind of in this weird out I had
this weird outof body experience for a
good chunk of that time where all of
these things were going on and there was
story lines or whatever and and all I
was thinking about was this guy if
anyone's not read The Alchemist by Pao
coo there's
this young Shepherd boy going on a
journey of self-discovery trying to find
out who he is and that really really
spoke to me at the time and I was in the
south coast of muor which is Spain and
it was in the middle of summer and I was
I read this book during the media
lockdown week and then went in in this
total fever dream um so my
experience of Love Island I don't think
is perfectly representative yeah some of
the things that I did realize were that
it teaches young
people that love is a game to be played
yeah that loyalty is
both super important and also
unbelievably disposable at the same time
like think about when love Island comes
on TV in the UK I'm teamed such and such
right like cardia or whatever like like
sis like you know like whatever way yeah
they they try and do that thing I'm team
this and then as soon as one person
decides they're going to move on
typically if it's a guy he's being
totally unfair if it's a girl maybe that
dude was a bummer if he was cute or like
sweet then that was her fault and she
shouldn't have done it it's so it it it
encourages people to make very quick
decisions to fall very hard very fast to
have loyalty but only kind of have
loyalty to someone who's likable like a
lot of people are unlikable people
deserve relationships too you know what
I mean like it's everybody needs
somebody um yeah it's it really does
it's like a popularity contest even in
there absolutely yeah of course of
course because you know the stat did you
get real emotions like real jealousy and
real anger or I didn't have a single
romantic emotion during love Island but
I had a lot of bromance no romance but a
lot of bromance right while I was in
there I cried when I left because I was
missing my boys like I didn't want to
leave my boys behind and i' had this
really intense emotional experience I'd
you know spent a lot of time I'd really
connected with guys while I was there
but I I the girls were perfectly
pleasant but I wasn't bothered about
leaving them behind affect your
self-esteem in anyway that it wasn't
connecting with the girls or not really
did you just find Val particularly I
just wasn't I really was not attracted
to any of them okay so that it was we
kept on
saying when the girls were coming in
everybody had a type right and I I I
don't think that they'd read necessarily
all of the guys sheets and you can see
that in the fact that there isn't a
single relationship from That season
that's still no one no even the winners
even the winners the winners last like
less time than anybody else okay um so
mhm Married at First Sight have you seen
this story I I am I'm a familiar with it
okay so for the people that don't know
the transgender bride set to take
Married at First Sight UK by storm
transitioned age 21 at an NHS hospital
before spending £50,000 on cosmetic
surgery to be taken seriously as a woman
mail online can reveal today Channel 4
viewers will see Ella Morgan 29 who was
born Evan Morgan wed a male contestant
and made a row over whether the groom
was told first or not Miss Morgan is
shown in the trailer for Married at
First Sight telling her new husband her
big secret after they married having
admitted her transition has made her
fear rejection after being treated as a
dirty secret in the past however Channel
4 has now revealed that they did tell
the man in advance he would be marrying
a trans woman it is understood that the
man is furious with how the broadcaster
treated him during the show and
afterward but the beauty and fashion
consultant from Bristol says she is
determined to be the star of the show to
shed light on the struggles and
realities of being trans adding we're
not free or mentally ill I'm still just
like any other
girl okay going to be difficult for you
to comment on this one s it is going to
be difficult I'm trying to see how I can
behave and not offend but here here's
the reality of it if I was even if I was
born a woman or whatever and I had
millions of Cosmetics procedures and I
have a higher risk of uh depression
because of the you know the lifestyle
I've chosen uh a man has every right to
know them and has every right to say
it's not for me it's not for me I
wouldn't be with a somebody who has born
a woman because it's just not for me I'm
a heterosexual woman and I'm entitled to
identify as that now um what I find the
thing is if it's really painful to be
transgender and it's a lot of suffering
I don't think it's good for TV to kind
of capitalize on that for views and TR
use that as somebody's suffering as a
form of views but I also say that it
does it does make you different from
other women if you're saying the trans
struggle it was really hard for you in
your childhood and you found it really
depressing that makes you different to
the woman that grew up in the body she
identifies with so to say that you're on
par with the typical woman is not true
because you've gone through a different
type of trauma that we haven't so
essentially you're never going to be
like a a woman not even just physically
but also psychologically you're never
going to be like a woman and it's okay
to never be like a woman it's okay the
thing that I find difficult to
understand about the whole trans debate
is one for many decades we were told
gender is a social construct it's just
this imaginary thing that we're telling
we've we've only been told that for
about one decade yeah we've been told
it's a a social construct everybody's
saying it's a social contract the
Liberals are saying it's a social
construct but then if you say that you
identify as the opposite gender they
give you biological treatment now if
it's a social construct essentially
you're only identifying as a social
construct you don't need to change your
biology it doesn't make any sense it's
like saying that your uh football team
who you support is a social construct I
don't need to change my biology to be a
man united supporter because essentially
it's a social construct so if gender is
a social construct why do we need to
transition I think the the argument on
the other side of the fence would be I
want my outer appearance to reflect my
inner experience then why not change
your inner experience rather than your
outer don't know whether they have
control over that but that's no
different to like for example anorexic
will genuinely believe that they are the
fattest person in the world they
identify as fat now the reality is I'm
not going to give them a lipos suction
so that their brain and their body are
aligned I have to look at the
psychological defect that caused them to
be unaligned and focus on the psychology
first and if that doesn't work then we
can look at biological procedures but
the reality is I don't see how when it
comes to anorexic I get that there's you
know self it's not healthy or whatever
it is but at the same time we know the
suicide rates and transgenders is not
healthy either we're doing them a
disservice by simply giving them a
shortcut to biological procedures while
skipping psychological interventions
yeah there's I had uh Hannah BS on the
show she did a big investigation into
gids the gender
identity something service that was at
the Tavistock clinic in the UK that's
recently been shut down and then kind of
restarted again and then the restart
kind of I think had some controversy as
well and um there is an unbelievably
high percentage of autism and OCD and
other sort of co- Psychopathology type
things uh in the trans community and
there is this big question that she
asked which was are people mentally
disturbed because they're trans or are
they trans because they're mentally
Disturbed yeah and there is a a question
to be asked that if untreated autism or
OT OCD or something like that if that
ended up getting treated whether the
gender dysphoria Downstream from that
would dissipate and that's a I think
that that would
encounter in some of the real like
Hardline trans communities I think that
would encounter some challenges because
they would say that almost by getting
rid of the autism you're denying the
person hood of the trans person because
it delegitimizes the gender dysphoria
and almost makes it like how the light
bulbs in here give off light but also
heat it's like oh the gender dysphoria
was a side effect of autism and we don't
know we don't know the direction of of
causality here but it's one of the most
heavily contested highly Hot Topics
would you be uh ostracize as like a a
man that chooses not to be with a
transgender woman in America depends why
you're talking about I mean this
discussion of are you allowed to have
your own preferences is fascinating
right you know if you prefer blondes is
that somehow prejudiced against
brunettes and gingers yeah if you prefer
tall girls is that somehow prejudice
against petite girls like the the line
between the question of are you are you
being either transphobic or homophobic
by not dating somebody who is
biologically the same sex as you but has
transitioned it it seems like a slippery
slope from there to just why shouldn't
you date somebody that self IDs as that
you know I don't need to do the external
comparison do you know Blair white you
familiar with her yeah so Blair's a good
friend I she looks more like a girl than
a lot of girls do right but I don't know
I if she was to get into a relationship
with somebody and not open up about she
hasn't had bottom surgery so it's a
surprise that's waiting to visit you at
some point yeah it's a fascinating
discussion I do think that the not
dating
transitioned
people is transphobic argument has kind
of been and gone anybody that genuinely
looks at that and says yeah you should
date how we tell you to date is it's
again like does that mean that I have to
date everybody why do I not have to be
attracted to my video guy like do you
know what I mean like I'm and allow have
preferences and yeah it becomes kind of
a self-defeating do you did you ever
hear about the study with Dr money and
the twins um so there was two twins that
went to hospital to get circumcised but
they accidentally burnt the penis off
one so what the doctors decided to do is
raise a child they were both boys but
raised a child that had his penis burnt
off as a woman as a girl so for the
first seven years of life they just put
her in dresses made her believe that she
was a girl everything was like you're
just a girl but as um the girl hit
puberty she felt more and more like a
boy and she she remembering being
suicidal saying I want to be a boy I
feel like a boy I want to play with like
the balls and I want to play sports and
So eventually they told him the truth
and he went back to being a boy because
he just the self-discovery of your
hormones but eventually ended up
committing suicide because of the trauma
so the whole idea of playing with
people's uh gender especially when they
do prepuberty because that study showed
that as soon as puberty hit in
completely a boy again so if you try
block uh like pu like the hormones
before puberty you're blocking them
their self-discovery that might occur
after hormones so it's quite a dangerous
thing to do we'll get back to talking to
sard in one minute but first I need to
tell you about Factor if you are too
busy this Autumn to cook but still want
to make sure that you're eating well
factor is the solution with Factor you
can skip the extra trip to the grocery
store plus all of the chopping and
prepping and cleaning up while still
getting the flavor and nutritional
quality that you need factors fresh
never frozen meals are ready in Just 2
minutes minutes so all you have to do is
heat and enjoy and right now their
Autumn menu has some absolute bangers
like a cranberry peacan chicken and an
apple Dijon pork chop or if like me
you're struggling to hit your protein
girls you can try their Protein Plus
meals with 30 G or more of protein per
serving I cannot tell you how big of a
life hack it is to only be 2 minutes
away from a 30 g of protein meal at all
times right now you can get 50% off by
heading to the link in the description
below or going to to factor meals.com
mw50 using the code mw50 a checkout
that's factor meals.com
mw50 and mw50 a checkout what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to
subscribe